okay
so here we go ready for
the final yeah
and this is mate okay try and see if i
can get him to stalemate me here
i'm assuming there's no chance okay yeah
no chance
oh boy yeah this is gonna be tough
you can go knight c6 yeah
page seven oh okay descendants mate okay
yeah this was a bad game mommy yeah this
is right
okay it's gonna resign
okay evening the score again but this
this is a tough match okay let me try
something else
okay draw i think i had winning position
[Music]
yeah and he's very fast in this side so
okay
oh that's a repetition
yeah i have no clue okay i'm just gonna
resign
that was so bad so so bad
okay yeah this was bad game
i had a very good position but i
blundered so badly
okay okay messy game
but once again
it's being so incredibly i mean i know
57 but yeah it takes
yeah this was a bad game
okay we'll see
okay okay
okay okay
oh no ah
okay
this is insane couldn't you too late
i should just give a check and win the
game man
that's okay what am i doing take it
come on so [ __ ] slow
wow
i could just have done it actually that
could be the point that wins me
the match okay that's me
okay i'm just playing so badly sure
before i take queen each five
takes takes knight d5
okay tough okay this is the last game
[Music]
okay let's go it's absolutely game over
so bad
24 i'm late
okay good game alright that was really
horrible
i i mean i just was way out of shape but
he deserves full credits
but i i just gotta be better but um yeah
he's
amazingly strong full credit
you